demonstrate his appeal to gang leaders
in Porto Prince to release Alex
Dawsonville an American nurse who was
kidnapped along with her daughter eight
days ago
she works for a charity that runs a
school and health clinic in City Soleil
an impoverished suburb of the capital
with a reputation for gang violence
this is a bad thing to have happened
because the lady was helping us working
with children it's really affected me
the kidnapping is very strange
the clinic where she worked is
temporarily closed but many worry it
won't reopen
population
we don't think people are ready to lose
all these benefits that's why we're
asking our brothers sisters please have
a little awareness free Alex so she can
come back and continue to help the
community
Haiti is a country with a collapsed
economy and no functioning government
gang violence has surged since the
assassination of President Jovan Almo
East two years ago since then there's
been violent protests demanding the
resignation of prime minister Ariel Omri
foreign
is run by criminal groups linked to the
surge in murders and kidnappings the U.N
Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez has
called for an international task force
to assist the fight against criminal
gangs
what Alex is going through today is not
happening just to her I mean it is a
difficult period everyone is passing
through hard times
the United States says it's working with
the Haitian authorities to secure
dawsonville's release those who know her
well say they'll keep protesting until
she's freed Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
[Applause]